San ELISA wait dick is 17 years old
the South African girl is committed to
combating violence in the community of
Nelson Mandela Bay once a week the
school girl visits the grave of her
friend Cindy brutally raped and murdered
two years ago filling off mixed emotions
because now it's my first time yeah the
burial I was last year at the Burnett
burial beg their newest stones in shock
because we didn't expect it I think now
it is sang in that we may never see
Sydney again maybe we'll see her in the
afterlife San Alyssa we dick lives in
Walmer township a poor neighborhood with
high levels of unemployment and violent
crime often young people are not only
the victims but also the perpetrators of
violence if you want to fit in you go
into this gang and then you do all sorts
of wrong stuff because you just want to
fit in yeah and then of course
unemployment also has a major role to
play and poverty but I think the main
reason is patient and perfect together
with some friends than ELISA way started
the project youth for safer communities
to make young people think about their
role in the creation of safer spaces the
NGO masa funda trains them how to best
promote their topic the three friends
have now been selected to present their
safety proposals to the mayor of the
city there's no reason why doesn't
remember one condition in this panel we
have faith in you we know that you guys
can do this we're tired of paying the
victims it's time that we took charge of
our lives and what is happening around
us so I want to show him that we can we
are part of the problem so we can't be
part of the solution
Sen Alyssa Wade dick wants young people
to take responsibility and to take
action for a healthy environment such as
renovating a rundown classroom the big
day has arrived
to present their proposals for a safer
city to the mayor now the first issue
was that everyone not everyone
contributes in the creation of safer
spaces people feel that it's the job of
the government or the police whereas
it's a shared responsibility you already
know the detail of the whole path I'm
very encouraged both by their own
stories of what they want to pursue in
future as well as the kind of society
and communities that they want to see in
the Metro together with her friends and
masa funda she will make sure that young
people will have their say about the
future of Nelson Mandela Bay